secretary general prime minister trudeau
prime minister wholeness thank you for
this opportunity and for your leadership
excellencies this virus
we are fighting comes with dangerous
side effects
one of them is the domino effect we risk
that the covet crisis sets off a number
of other crises
especially in developing countries adept
crisis
with a worrying number of developing
countries on the brink
of default an education crisis
with millions of children forced out of
education
a crisis of rising inequalities both
between countries
and within countries and we also risk a
co2 crisis
if we do not invest decisively in a
green recovery
but they can all be averted with the
right
investment and with action at global
level
and this is why we meet today every
country in this world
should be able to focus on two parallel
strands of work
on the one hand the fight against the
pandemic
as team europe we have just doubled our
contribution to the covex facility
but the global vaccination campaign
needs
more investment so let me invite
everyone to contribute
the other strand of work is a green
economic recovery
with the sustainable development goals
at its core
precisely for this reason last year i
proposed a global recovery initiative
that links investment and debt relief
to progress towards the sustainable
development
goals one year on
i would like to announce europe's
support to three
initiatives first we support a new
general
allocation of special drawing rights in
2021
with the focus on low-income countries
in need
let us discuss how we do it
but countries in need should get our
help
right now second
europe has just announced a new
contribution of 183 million euros
to the catastrophe containment and
relief
trust of the imf but more contributions
are necessary
to extend the debt relief period
and third we welcome the agreement at
the g20
on the common framework for debt
treatments
the scope of the common framework could
be extended
beyond low-income countries to help
restructure
unsustainable debt for middle-income
countries too
this is a moment to refocus our
investment agendas towards the
sustainable development goals
the next milestone in this work is the
global health
summit that europe and italy will host
in may
we will focus on the preparedness of our
health systems
in line with goal three from the
sustainable development goals
together we can prevent the domino
effect
and build forward better thank you